IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
THIS SATURDAY IS READ-A-BOOK
DAY, AND IT'S ALSO CHRIS
CHRISTIE'S BIRTHDAY, SO WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD ARBITRARILY TIE
TWO EVENTS YOU PROBABLY DON'T
CARE ABOUT TOGETHER WITH
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG #JERSEYABOOK.
#JERSEYABOOK.
SEE, NOW YOU CARE ABOUT THOSE
THINGS, RIGHT?
(LAUGHTER)
EXAMPLES WOULD BE, UH, "OTHELLO.
EH! THIS FUCKIN' GUY."
OR "ULYSSES.
NO YO LISEES."
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT WAS A GOOD ONE.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
OLD CLOCK.
AND GO. LET'S BEGIN.
JIM JEFFERIES.
>> UH, CATCHER IN THE FACE.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. POINTS.
(LAUGHTER AND GROANING)
POINTS. JIM JEFFERIES.
>> UH, THE JERSEY SHORE SHANK
REDEMPTION.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. NICE.
OH, GOOD.
>> THAT WAS A GOOD ONE.
>> HARDWICK: WHITNEY CUMMINGS.
>> ARE YOU THERE, GOD?
BECAUSE NEW JERSEY IS MAKING ME
THINK YOU DON'T EXIST.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, POINTS. GOOD.
YEAH. JIM.
>> CHARLIE AND THE CHOCOLATE
FACTORY OUTLET.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
POINTS. WHITNEY CUMMINGS.
>> MOBY DICK PICKS.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
POINTS. POINTS.
(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
WHITNEY AGAIN.
>> OH, 50 SHADES OF ORANGE.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
CHRIS.
>> MY THING DOESN'T WORK!
IT DOESN'T WORK!
>> HARDWICK: CHRIS D'ELIA.
CHRIS D'ELIA.
>> OF MICE AND MEN, YOUSE GUYS.
(LAUGHTER)
COME ON, MAN.
(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
CHRIS D'ELIA.
>> UH... THE ADVENTURES OF
HUCKLEBERRY FUHGET-ABOUT-IT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
>> GOOD ONE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
WHITNEY CUMMINGS.
>> CATCH 22 VENEREAL DISEASES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
CHRIS D'ELIA.
>> MRS. DALLOWAY. SHE BLEW ME.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT. COOL.
YEAH, MAN!